it does feel like math and physics are
both sneaking up to a deep truth
from slightly different angles and you
stand at the crossroads or at the
intersection of the two it's interesting
to ask what do you think is the
difference between physics and
Mathematics in the way physics and
Mathematics look at the world
there is actually an essential
difference
which is that physicists are interested
in describing this universe
okay mathematicians are interested in
describing all possible mathematical
universes of which uh you know and some
of our work I still consider myself more
of a mathematician than a physicist My
First Love for physics notwithstanding
mathematicians are in a way
we have more diversity if you if you you
might say so we we are accepting for
instance uh our universe has three
special spatial dimensions in one time
Dimension right so what I mean is that
allegedly allegedly observed but that
way you can observe today right so of
course there are theories where there
are some hidden Dimensions as well I
mean let's just say absorbed You observe
dimensions
um so this tabletop has two Dimensions
because you can have two axis two
coordinate axes now X and Y but then
there is also a third one to describe
the space of this room
and then there's a Time Time Dimension
so realistic theories of physics have to
be
about
spaces of three three dimensions or
space time so four dimensions but
mathematically we are just as interested
in theories in 10 space time Dimensions
or 11 or 25 or whatever or or infinite
dimensional spaces you know
so that's the difference
on the other hand I have to give it to
the physicists we don't have the same
satisfaction that they have of having
their theories
um confirmed by an experiment we don't
get to play with big machines like LHC
in Geneva large andron collider that
recently discovered you know the Higgs
boson and some other things
for us it's all like a mental exercise
in some sense we do we prove things by
using rules of logic and that's our way
of confirming experimental confirmation
if you will but I think we kind of I
kind of Envy a little bit my friends
visits that they they get to they get to
experience this sort of this big toys
you know and play with them but it does
seem that sometimes as you've spoken
about abstract mathematical Concepts map
to reality and it seems to happen quite
a bit that's right so the mathematics is
the underpins physics obviously it's a
language the the book of nature
famously said it's written in the
language of mathematics and and the you
know the the letters in it are the
circles triangles and squares and those
who don't know the language I'm
paraphrasing
are left to wander in a dark Labyrinth
that's a famous quote from Galileo which
is very true and has become even more
true more recently and in theoretical
physics in the more in the most
um act sort of
for out
um parts of the theoretical physics that
have to do with Elementary particles and
and as well as the the structure of the
cosmos at the large scale what do you
think of uh Max tag Mark or wrote the
book mathematical universe
so do you think just lingering on that
point you think at the end of the day
the future Generations will all be
mathematicians
meaning meaning the ones that deeply
understand the way the universe works at
the core is it just
mathematics
at the core of you know
I would say mathematics is one half of
the core so the book is called love and
math yeah okay so these are the two
pillars
yeah in my view yes in other words you
can't cover everything by math so
mathematics gives you tools it gives you
way up uh
kind of a clear
vision
but mathematics by itself is not enough
for one to have a harmonious and and
balanced life you know so I I am
suspicious of any theory that
declares that everything is mathematics
so math can generate things that are
beautiful but you can't explain why it's
beautiful Matthew could say is a way to
discern patterns to find regularities in
the universe and both physical and
mental Universe the mathematics explores
the mind as much as it explores
um the physical world around us and it
helps us to find those patterns
um which kind of which makes our
perception more sophisticated our
ability to perceive things such as
Beauty
you know and uh it sharpens our ability
to see to see beauty to understand
Beauty so our world becomes more complex
from thinking that our
that our that Earth is flat we go to
realizing that it is round that it's
shaped as a sphere
so that we can actually travel around
the Earth you know so there isn't a
place where we hit the end so to speak
and then
um
proceeding in the same vein then
Einstein's general relativity Theory
tells us that
our space-time is not flat either
this is much harder to to imagine the
band a band three-dimensional or
four-dimensional three-dimensional space
or four-dimensional space-time because
this idea that the space around us is
flat is so deeply entrenched and yet we
know from this from this Theory
and from the experiments that have
confirmed it
that
array of light bends around a star as if
being attracted by the by the force of
gravity but in fact the force of gravity
is the bending it's just that it's not
only depending on the space it's also
the bending of space-time there is a
curvature
not only between special spatial
dimensions
the way parallels and meridians come
together in a small scale they look like
perpendicular lines but if you zoom out
you see that the space are they curving
the space they are sort of the the
tracks along which the space gets curved
that's that's the that would be the
curvature of spatial Dimensions but in
fact now throw in time and one time
imagine a sphere which lives which has
one of the meridians correspond to time
and the perilous crisp into space I
can't imagine it but you can I can write
mathematical formula expressing that
curvature and that's in fact that
curvature is responsible for the force
of gravity attraction between the sort
of simplest instantiation of it
attraction between two planets all
between two human beings
yeah the time
bending time
it's not very nice that what that theory
did to time because
it feels like the marching of time
forward is fundamental to our Human
Experience
the arrow of time
marching forward nicely
seems to be the only way we can
understand the universe and the fact
that you can start now up to now there
are people who claim that they can that
they have they possess other ways of of
experiencing it so truly can visualize
messing with time
well messing with time but not
necessarily messing with time because
one point of view is that you know
I think who who was it I think William
Blake
who wrote that
eternity loves time production
so
one point of view is that it is eternity
which is fundamental where time stands
still which our mind conceptualizes as
the time
so but in fact you know it's not
something mystical if you think about
when you about it
when you really absorbed in something
time does the stand still and then you
look at the clock and it's like oh my
God two hours have passed and it felt
like a couple of seconds
when you are absorbed when you're in
love when you are passionate about
something when you're creating something
you're we lose ourselves and we lose the
sense of time and space for that matter
you see so there is only that which is
happening that creative process
um so I think that this is familiar to
all of us and we may be actually the
closest to the truth at that moment to
the truth so yes so then there is a
point of view that this is where we are
We Are Who We Are at our sort of
fundamental at our fundamental level and
after that the Mind comes in
and tries to conceptualize it it's like
oh because I was writing something
um
I was writing a book I was painting this
painting or maybe I was watching this
painting and got totally absorbed in it
or I fell in love with this person
that's what happened but in the moment
when it's happening you're not thinking
about it
you're just there yeah we construct
narratives around the set of memories
that that seem to have happened in
sequence or at least that's the way we
tell ourselves that and we also have a
bunch of weird human things like
Consciousness and the experience of free
will that we chose a set of actions as
the time unrolled forward right and we
are intelligent conscious agents making
tastes taking those actions
but what if all of that is just an
illusion an illusion and a nice
narrative would tell ourselves sure
that's a really difficult thing possible
and imagine imagine that to make it
really Catch-22 that I'll imagine that
our minds and are set up in such a way
yeah
that they can't approach the world or
experience otherwise
so in other words to understand to see
that from a more
um kind of all-encompassing point of
view we have to step out of the Mind
well I wonder what's the more honest way
to look at things
but I think we like to be to play with
time I think we like to play with these
experiences with all the drama of it
with all the memories with all the
tribulations I think we love it we love
it otherwise we wouldn't be doing it I
think this or Earth loves it The
evolutionary process somehow loves it
whatever whatever this thing that's
being created here on Earth it seems to
like to create like to allow its
children to play with certain uh yeah
truths that they hold this subjective
truths that are useful for the
competition or whatever this dance that
we call Life broadly Define not just
humans and and you know I'm glad you
mentioned that because
what I find fascinating is that the
greatest scientists are on record
saying that when they were making their
discoveries they felt like children so
Isaac Newton said to myself I only
appeared as a child playing on the
seashore and every once in a while
finding a prettier Pebble or a prettier
shell whilst I think some he says
something like the infinite ocean of
knowledge late late was lying before me
who probably it was the greatest
mathematician of the second half of the
20th century the French mathematician
Alexander grotonic
wrote that Discovery is a privilege of a
child
the child who is not afraid to be wrong
once again to build to look like an
idiot you know to to try this and that
and paraphrasing and go through trial
and error that is for them in other
words for them
that innocence
of a child who is not afraid
who has not yet been told that it could
not be done okay
that was essential to Scientific pursuit
to scientific discovery
and now and now also compared to Pablo
Picasso a great artist right so who said
every every child is an artist the
question is to how to preserve that as
we grow up
do you struggle with that you're one of
the most respected
mathematicians in the world
uh your Berkeley you're like this this
is the statue you're supposed to be very
like you know yeah sometimes I joke I
say I I think I take an elevator to the
top of the Eiffel Tower every day yeah
and you're supposed to speak like
royalty uh do you struggle to let uh
strip all of that away to ReDiscover the
child when you're thinking about
problems when you're teaching when
you're thinking about the world
absolutely I mean that's part of being
human because when we grow up I mean all
of them all of these great scientists I
think they were so great in part because
they were able they can maintain that
connection okay in that Fascination that
vulnerability
um that spontaneity you know and uh
um kind of looking at the World Through
The Eyes of a child but it's difficult
because you know you go through
education system and for many of us
uh it's not especially
helpful for maintaining that connection
that'd be kind of like we're being told
certain things that we accept
take for granted and so on and little by
little and also we get hit every time we
act different okay every time we act
that that's in a way that doesn't fit
sort of the pattern we get punished by
the teachers get punished by
parents and so on and don't get respect
when you act childlike in in your
thinking when you are fearless and
uh looking like an idiot that's right
because there's a hierarchy nobody wants
to look like an idiot you know once you
start growing up or you think you're
growing up yeah in the beginning you
don't even think of you don't think in
these terms you just play you're just
playing
and you are open to possibilities to
these infinite possibilities that this
world presents to us so how do we I'm
not saying that
education system should not be also uh
kind of taming that a little bit
obviously
the goal is balance
that acquiring knowledge
so that
we can be more mature and more
discerning more discriminating in terms
of our approach to the world in terms of
our connections to the world and people
and so on but how would do we do that
while also preserving that innocence of
a child
and my guess is that there is no formula
for this
it is
a life is an answer every life every
human being is one particular answer to
how do we find balance
that's once imperfect approximation
approximate solution
we can look up to the great ones yeah
who have
credentials in the sense that they have
shown and they have proved that they
have done something that other humans
appreciate our civilization appreciates
say Isaac Newton or Alexander grotonic
or Pablo Picasso so they have
established their rights to speak about
this matters and we cannot dismiss them
as mere Madman
they say okay well if if the same thing
was said by somebody who never achieved
anything in in that in their in their
field of endeavor you would be it would
be easy for us to dismiss it but when it
comes from someone like Isaac Newton
we take notice
so I think it's something important that
they teach us and especially today in
this age of AI
of course there's a big elephant in the
room always which is called AI yeah
right and so I know that you are an
expert in this subject
and we are going we're living now in
this very interesting times of new AI
systems coming online pretty much every
couple of weeks
so
I kind of um to me that whole debate
about
what is it what is artificial
intelligence where is it going what
should we do about it
needs an influx of this type of
considerations that we've just been
talking about
that for instance the idea that
inspiration creativity doesn't come from
accumulation of knowledge because
obviously child a child has not yet
accumulated knowledge and yet the great
ones are on record saying that a child
has a capacity
to to create
and at an adult
credits the inner child the inner child
yeah for this capacity to create as an
adult you see that's kind of weird if we
take the point of view
that everything is computation
everything is accumulation of knowledge
that just bigger and bigger data sets
finer and finer neural networks and then
we will be able to replicate human
consciousness if we take that point of
view then what I just said kind of
doesn't fit because obviously a child
has not been fed any training data as
far as we know yeah they're perfectly
capable of of you know of distinguishing
between cats and dogs for instance and
stuff like that but much more than that
they're also capable of that
you know wide-eyed in a sort of
perspective
so does can it really be captured that
perspective that sense of or can it
really be captured by competition alone
I actually I don't know the answer so
I'm not sort of trying to
uh to present a particular point of view
understand to question
um any theory that starts out by saying
life is this or Consciousness is this
because when you look more closely you
recognize that there are some other
things at play
which do not quite fit the narrative
and it's hard to know where they come
from it's it's also possible that the
evolutionary process has created
is the very it is computation and the
child is actually not a blank slate but
the result of one of the most incredible
several billion year old computations
uh that
that had explored all kinds of aspects
of of life on Earth
of of war and love and Terror and
ambition and violence and invention all
of that from the bacteria to today so
like that young child is not is not a
blank slate they call me they're they're
actually they hold within them the
knowledge of several billions of years
right the question is whether as a child
you carry that in the form of the kind
of computational algorithms that we are
aware today you see what what strikes me
as unlikely
is that
how should I put it how interesting that
you know we you you are a computer
scientist and there are other people
come I have studied computer science so
I know a little bit
and so it's tempting to say
oh
the whole world
is computer science or is based can be
explained by computer science yes why
because it makes me feel good because I
have mastered it I have learned it my
ego is very happy and people come to me
and and and they look up to me and they
Revere me kind of like priests in the
old in old days when religion was
Paramount when when you would be would
tend to explain things in theological
religious terms today science has
progressed there are fewer people who
kind of buy into religion official
religion you know so
we have this urge I suppose to to
explain and to know and to dissect and
to analyze and to conceptualize which is
a wonderful quality that we have and we
should definitely pursue that but I find
it a little bit
unlikely
that the universe is just exactly what I
have learned
and not something that I don't know you
see
well there's a lot of interesting
aspects of the current large language
models
that one perspective of it I think
speaks to the love and math that you
talk to which is
they're trained on
the human data from the internet
so at its best a large language model
like gpt4
captures the magic of The Human
Condition on its full display it's full
complexity
as it's mimicking it's trying to
compress all the weirdness of humans
of all the debates and discussions the
perspectives all the different ways that
people approach solving different
problems all of that compressed so we
live we're each individual ants we only
have like we have a family we interact
with a few little ants and here comes AI
That's able to summarize like a tldr
report of humanity and that's the beauty
of it so I embrace it but I wonder I'm
very impressed by it I wonder if
they can be very impressive meaning
way more impressive in being able to
fake or simulate or emulate a human
thing I'm glad you mentioned that
because that's just it seems to be the
Mantra it's just fake fake it till you
make it yeah isn't it isn't that what we
all do though no yes we do that but we
also do other things we can be truly in
love we can be truly inspired when it is
not fake I do believe call me a romantic
okay but I do believe
and this is a very good I'm glad you're
putting it in these terms because I've
had conversations like that that yeah
fake it till you make it but that's like
that's what humans do yes we do that but
not all the time so and that is
debatable because also I speak from my
own experience and that's where the
first person perspective comes in the
subjective view I cannot prove to you
for instance or anyone else that there
are certain moments in my life where I
am genuine I am pure so to speak when
it's not faking it but I do I do have a
tremendous
a certainty of it and that's a
subjective certainty now I am as a
scientist I'm also trained to give more
um credibility to objective arguments
that and other things that can be
reproduced things that I can demonstrate
that I can show
but as I get older there we go as I get
more mature hopefully you know
I'm starting to question why I am not
giving as much
credibility to my subjective
understanding of the world the kind of
the first person perspective when
actually modern science has already sold
on that you know quantum mechanics
has shown unambiguously that the
Observer is always involved in the
observation
likewise yodel's incompleteness
ethereums to me
shows how essential
is the Observer of the mathematical
theory for one thing that's the one who
chooses the axioms and we can talk about
this in more detail likewise Einstein's
relativity where
time is relative to The Observer for
instance that's brilliant you're just
describing all of these different scales
The Observer what they Observer